two and a half years ago Christmas 2012
my family went to London with the hope
of saving our sons life we went to try a
medicine drive from cannabis that we
hoped would stop Sam's unrelenting
seizures I'm Fred vogelstein I'm a
writer in the Bay Area I wrote about our
quest and photographer Eleanor Karrueche
made these beautiful and moving images
of our family for wired Sam doesn't have
the kind of seizures you see on TV they
only last about 10 seconds but when they
are uncontrolled which has been often he
can have more than a hundred a day I'm
still haunted by them and I've seen them
tens of thousands of times we'd already
tried two dozen medications without
success we tried cannabis-based potions
in the u.s. to the compound we were
after is called cannabidiol or CBD it
doesn't get you high the problem is
extracting it from the cannabis plant
it's difficult and it's made even harder
in the US because of our cannabis laws
but in London a drug company GW
pharmaceuticals was making CBD on an
industrial scale as a component of
another medicine and they agreed to let
Sam come to Britain to try CBD alone for
epilepsy Sam responded immediately
the day he arrived in London with his
twin sister Beatrice and my wife Evelyn
he had nearly 70 seizures and three days
later he had only six it took four
months to get the FDA and DEA approvals
we needed to import the medicine into
the US but today not only a Sam nearly
seizure free he fences three times a
week and as a normal active teenager his
experience appears to have jump-started
GWS development of a new drug to treat
epilepsy the drug epidemics could get
FDA approval by 2018